This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
Hello and welcome everyone. Let's go
ahead and open up those Zoom room doors
and let everyone in. My name is Ruth
Ellen Sanchez and I'm going to be your
host today for Daily with Doc and Becca.
And always give a shout out to Becca.
can't wait till you're back and I hope
you're having a good time. Um, also
this program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
and if somebody referred you to this
program, please make sure to get back
with them because they are going to be
your absolute point of contact and one
more thing that I have to do. This
program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, or cure cure or prevent
any diseases, nor is it intended to take
the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA and testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results may vary and may
not be typical and we do not make any
claims regarding health or income as an
empowered individual.
You do have options.
So today we have a very special guest.
So, I'm very excited
that Raymond Brown is going to be
joining us today. And he is a
motivational speaker and just a
powerhouse.
And um him and his wife Yolanda are like
an amazing couple. And together they're
like
dynamite. They're just amazing. And I
love them so much. So, um I'm going to
go ahead and bring Raymond on with me.
And um
I just I'm really looking forward to
what Raymond is going to share. I'm
sorry. I just had to do some real quick.
>> Come on.
>> There we go.
I forgot to
>> We all on the same team.
>> Yes, we are. I know. And you know,
that's one of the things I love about
you guys and you
you make people feel comfortable
like
there's no judgment. It's just love.
>> Yeah.
>> And you always have words of wisdom.
I've never ever heard you speak an
unkind word about anyone or anything
ever.
>> So, and we're all human, so I'm not
and we make mistakes, but you're just
It's really wonderful.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what are we talking about today?
>> Well, we uh we discussed um
one of the the the principles of we take
ourselves with us no matter where we go,
right? As human beings or as beings,
spiritual beings, whatever, we always
take ourselves where wherever we go. And
um
uh so you want me to just go ahead and
start rallying or reading or whatever
I'm going to do?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> I want to pre I want to premise this uh
Ruth Ellen by saying, you know, um
for some reason when I was a young man,
I I knew that I was different in the way
that I thought.
And not that I I thought I was better or
anything like that, but when people
would do things and say things, I
noticed how most of the the people in
the crowd or in the classroom or in the
family or wherever we were would think a
certain way. And I didn't I didn't think
that way, right? And I don't know if
that was I was born with it or or you
know or I developed it some kind of way.
I don't know. And it it kind of goes
back to you know why some people pursue
uh wisdom and why some people don't.
I've never come to a conclusion of are
there people born to be that way and
everybody else not? Are there some
people born to to to to to pursue the
light and other people pursue to be or
just choose to be normal and go along
with the crowd? That's something I've
never figured out. But if I do, guys,
I'mma write a book, right? And we all
gonna uh profit from the proceeds. How
about that? Good deal.
>> Yes, it's a good good deal. Thank you.
>> Good deal. So when when Yolanda and I
first came into the industry of network
marketing uh guys um we were uh
programmed to
uh programmed for business. It was all
about reaching your goals and dreams and
and trying to uh secure your family
financially, you know, those types of
things. And so uh the product
we had a wonderful product but most
people were trying to you know buy extra
bedroom set or kitchen net or you know a
stove or car help or make a car payment
with the money they were earning. We we
didn't talk about much about the
product. Now, don't get me wrong. I
think that
I don't want to want to set the table
where, you know, we didn't have any
scruples or or morals or anything. We
were just just money hungry. But
as far as Yolanda and I was concerned, I
wanted to secure my family uh as as much
as possible. If there was something
possible that I could do, I wanted to
secure my family. uh if if if if that's
if there is such a thing. And all I
wanted guys was basically, you know,
you've heard me say this a thousand
times. Uh we live in in Sugarland or in
Houston and we have hurricanes and bad
weather here and floods and things like
that. And I just said that look, if I
could earn an extra $3,000 a month, this
was 26 years ago, this is year 2000, if
we could uh earn enough where I said
$33,000,
$3,500 would be enough for me to if our
house got flooded like a lot of the
houses here do, uh, I could get us a a
small apartment, a a car, small car, and
put food on the table and regardless of
what happens, right? Uh and and or if we
had to leave this city uh because of the
flooding or whatnot, wherever we go, we
could find a little place and we could
we could live. And that's basically what
I set out to do. Now, I also wanted to
help people at the same time. And that's
where the product came in. So
in order for for me to uh I understood
in order for me to reach those goals I
had to deal with people and really that
is the product. People are our product
not the product because the product
doesn't sell itself. We the product
doesn't initially deal with people. We
deal with people they believe us or not
believe us or we form the relationship
with them or not. The product doesn't do
that. So I wanted to understand as much
as possible about human beings and the
way we think, the way we act and all of
those things in order for me to um
to deal with people on a successful
basis. Um
so that's what I set out to do reading
books and listen I've been been studying
spiritual principles for probably 55 56
years or so and uh but this but that was
for just individual purposes but for um
businesswise
I I had to understand I had to I I knew
that I had to understand people uh and
if I wanted to get where I wanted to go
uh for me and my family. I that was one
thing I had to do and I couldn't
shortcut it and I didn't want to depend
on luck or happen stances or anything
like that. Right? So uh I started
reading and studying people uh and our
behavior. And then I I learned that uh
there are certain principles that that
that govern us as human beings uh and as
spiritual beings. And I learned some of
those principles. Now I'm sure I haven't
learned all of them uh but that's
exciting because that means I got
something to look forward to, something
to learn. I'm a student of life and I
hope most of us are. The the only reason
we're here, guys, is to evolve. That's
the only reason we're put here. So, that
was kind of the the the the foundation
of my of me and Yolanda's beginning of
of of this this beautiful industry. So,
what I did today, uh, Ruth Ellen and and
and gang, I wrote down a few things and,
um, I I just wanted to at the at the be
very beginning of this, I want everybody
to take what you want and leave the rest
because I've unders, you know, some
people when you start talking about
personal stuff and spiritual stuff,
people will say, well, that's that's
I don't believe that. Well, that's what
I mean by uh take what you want and
leave the rest. I'm not here to to
advocate that my way is the only way and
the best way. I it's the best way for me
and it comes from my personal and long
personal experiences in this business
and in life. So, um so take what you
want and leave leave the rest, right? So
don't leave here saying well Raymond
said this and said this. No, everybody
have and ha have had their own spirit
their own experiences in life and that's
what we what we operate from right and
that's why you can find two people can
look at the same thing and see something
totally different. Have have I noticed
this. Have you ever like looked at a
person and they remind you of somebody
exactly of another person, a movie star
or another person, a neighbor or
somebody you knew growing up growing up
and then you you you say that to your
your your husband, your wife, or your
brother, sister, whoever. You say,
"Don't that look like so and so?" And
they'll say things like, "Yeah, I kind
of that kind of kind of favor them, but
to you it looks exactly like that
person." So we come here with different
uh perspectives and different
experiences.
And that's why you can see, you heard me
say this before I think with Ellen on
your the last time I I spoke, is that
you can take um
uh a guy and a girl and they get into a
relationship and
something happens and and she says that
I can't believe that you said that to
me. Well, from his experience in life,
his family, maybe that was normal and
it's not out of the the the realm of
normal for him, but to her that was way
out of bounds, right? And so that's
where we we come in the conflict uh well
conflict set in is because we have we
all have different experiences and we
bring our different experiences to life
and to relationships and to everything
like even these speeches I mean what I'm
talking about now you know the way you
comprehend something
is different than the way somebody else
comprehend uh uh what I'm saying because
their experiences are different in life
and what they've experienced and that's
the only reason why. So take what you
want and leave the rest. So
um life can be difficult or it can be
easy.
And as Michael Single said says so when
life is life is basically difficult
because we don't get what we want. And
have you ever noticed that it's easy
when we're getting everything we want?
That's kind of what what it boils down
to. And that's why we suffer. We suffer
because we're not getting what we want.
And so if we don't get what we want, we
suffer. And so uh in reality, that's why
we suffer. That means that unless we
discover how to do something
differently, we're going to suffer
pretty much all the time. Uh
even when we get what we want, even when
we get what we want,
we get to that place and we get the way
the mind works, we get scared we're
going to lose it. Oh Lord, how long is
this going to last? uh what can I do to
make him stay or her stay or what can I
do for to make them uh continuously like
me you know on the job or friendship or
whatever you know so the mind is always
in conflicts is a very disturbed place
to be uh so we start when we uh we start
worrying about how to keep it or
worrying about how to
when we might or worried about when we
might lose it. So, uh
the only way uh that that that I've
learned over life and and this may help
you is to is is to relax in life. Has
everybody anybody ever heard me or
anybody say that the first principles of
success in life is to learn to relax
first.
And that is the first principle. I don't
care guys what we're doing. Uh whether
we're handling a difficult problem,
whether it's physical or whether it's
mental or whatever the case may be,
whether we're doing a three-way call or
whatever, is learn to relax. And we all
have been through that process before of
learning how to relax. And how to relax
is I just just one of the ways I learned
is this and it helped me out
tremendously.
It just says I don't care if you going
to a meeting or you're getting ready to
get on a call, a difficult call where
you're going to, you know, it may be um
not so kind or it's going to be
difficult is to relax your shoulders,
relax your chest, relax your stomach,
and relax your hips. And that's just one
of the little things you can help in
life that will help you. Even when
you're at the grocery store, you're
standing there and you got all this
stuff going on through your mind, you
just learn to relax. So, this one of the
things that that I've learned over the
years that will help me uh uh stay out
of a lot of stress. Just that simple uh
uh uh uh knowing, just that that that
simple physical
uh uh um uh exercise will change
everything in your life. Just learning
to relax, you keep that stress off of
you. And and I one of the things I
learned is this. Stressing and worrying
about has never changed it anyway. Now,
that's easy to say, but if you're not
practicing that during the daytime or
nighttime or whenever, if you're not
practicing that enough, it won't happen
when those stressful times come. We'll
just react to the way we've been
reacting all of our lives and the way
everybody else reacts to some something.
So, one of the principles you want to
learn to do is release and relax.
release and relax. So, uh
how many how many of of us I would like
to ask you can ask this yourself. How
many of us um
have uh
been sitting around for years and
thinking about our past and thinking
about how we can change the past.
Somebody said something to us in the
third grade or our mother said something
to our father said something to us or
did something to us and we carry that
stuff for the rest of our lives
knowing that we can't change it. I like
to ask ask people to ask themselves can
you undo anything when it's already been
dra.
But the way the mind works, it makes us
sit there in that stuff that something
that happened 50 years ago and we're
still mad at that person or what our
parents did or what our mother said. We
have to learn to let that stuff go,
right? So we have all these me the
reason why we can't get to the place
that we want to be and be at peace is
because we have all these mental
blockages, right? And so until we learn
how to do that, we just suffer in life
now. We we're so used to it that it's
just part of who we are. And that's not
the way that's not natural for us to do.
That's very uh unnatural. It's just that
we've been taught that way or everybody
else does it and so we just follow along
to get along. But on the other hand,
nobody teaches us any differently. And
that's what one of the things that
really uh gets to me, you know, when you
go to these seminars and all this kind
of stuff and they tell you how to do
this and well, they tell you what to do,
what to do, but they don't tell you and
be at peace and and and you should live
in abundance and all that, but they
don't tell you how to do it. Not the
they tell you about behavior things.
Don't behave that way. Well,
behavior has never really changing your
behavior has never really worked because
when put under stress or in certain
situations,
our old patterns and behaviors
show up again.
And that's why unless we change
ourselves from at the spiritual core,
we don't really change. And that's why I
say you take yourself with you. If you
if somebody guys, if somebody is acting
up and being dishonest and you know they
are
when they come into your group, unless
they're doing some type of spiritual
work and they're doing it from an
honest, sincere uh u um uh stance,
they're going to do the same thing. I've
had people to leave other organizations
and come to ours and I I I appreciate
that. I like the volume but they they
bring themselves with them or or
whatever or we or I take myself with me.
I don't want to you know talk about
anybody. We take ourselves with you us
no matter where we go unless we're doing
the work and that includes relationships
or organizations or anything. So
expecting other people to be different,
uh you're setting yourself up for for
heartbreak. Um uh Angelo Maya Angelo
said this. She said,
"When somebody shows you who they are,
believe them,
right? But for some reason, we think
that they're going to change because
they come into our environment or to our
space or our organization or our
relationship with us because if I treat
them nice enough, they're just missing
that. If I treat them nice enough, if
I'm kinder, if I'm wiser, maybe they'll
change.
Now, there are some caveats to that. If
a person wants to change and you're that
leader or you're that that kind of
person that people want to be like, then
yeah. But if you think that you're going
to push your will on theirs or if here's
one of the ones I me and Yolanda run
across uh they're not teachable.
We run across that a lot of times people
especially when they've been successful
in life to a certain degree or they've
earned money. I won't say successful
because this business requires one of
the things that it requires guys is
change is growth. That's what I love
about it. You can go work for anybody.
IBM,
Microsoft,
AI, it doesn't matter. And you can go
there and as long as you can be a phony
and get that work done, you don't have
to grow. In this industry, you truly
becomes your become your brother's
keeper. And I love that because it
requires and the people that don't do it
normally just don't move that far ahead.
Now, I do want to want to say one thing
about success and uh money. There are
people that make money and on the
outside they look like they're
successful. They got it all together,
but people that that that that have that
are immoral
to a degree, what I'm saying, you know,
um that's dishonest.
They may look like they're success. They
have money. Well, they might have money,
but inside they're suffering. And that's
why they always start got to stay busy
or be doing something so their minds
doesn't so they don't settle long enough
to have to think about what they're
doing to other people and they're always
busy. And to us it look like, oh, oh,
he's so busy. He he he success. No, not
necessarily not. He's doing that to run
from himself basically. So,
uh, so I guess I I the next thing I
wanted to say is that as far as our
minds are concerned, guys,
here's here's another thing that that
I've learned. You you know, we've been
taught reading these positive thinking
books, well, just think positive, you
know, and just think about your goal.
Now, I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with that, but but what I'm saying
if you're dealing with life, I'm just
talking about life, not the business of
life. Do you know that you can't beat
your mind? And we spend all of our lives
trying to beat our mind, trying to
control it, and you can't do it. Your
our minds are just too disturbed. The
patterns are just too deep. You cannot
beat your mind. If you think one day I'm
going to sit here and I'm going to
grapple with it my mind and I'm going to
beat it and when I get it right where I
want it, it's I'm going to be at peace.
Well, you can't beat the mind. The mind
doesn't work that way.
The mind is very disturbed and if you
try and beat it or fight it, it's going
to beat you in the end and you're going
to suffer.
So that's why they say surrender and it
goes back to to uh uh to this. Most of
us have heard uh we've fallen from the
garden of Ed. I'm just going to go ahead
and throw that in there. We've fallen
from the garden of Eden. Eden. Well,
that happened, guys.
basically and the things that I'm
talking about you can apply in any in
every area of your life your business
every area see these things must be done
be before
we get to where you want to be so the
goal is not to acquire the goal is to be
first then the acquire and there's
nothing wrong you've heard me say this
with having the big homes the big houses
the big cars the beautiful relationship
ship, but understand
that
that's not who you are. You're much
bigger than you. We all are much bigger
than that. And when you hear people say
that, well, we're limitless. Well,
they're not talking about or you hear,
you know, authors or or or people uh of
the clergy or whoever wise
people say, uh, we're much bigger than
that, right? Or you hear people say that
we're limitless. Well, what that means
when we're we're when they say we're not
limitless, that's that doesn't mean that
we're not physically limitless because
we are. And that doesn't mean that we
are
are mentally limitless. What that means
is that we are spiritually, the real us
is limitless. And I'll try and back this
up by saying this. So we are not our
physical bodies per se. We are not our
minds but we are our soul. You can call
it the soul, the spirit, the
subconscious, whatever fits your fancy
or you're comfortable with, right? You
can ask a thousand people what it is and
there you'll get a thousand different
answers. And the ego kicks in and says,
"Well, it's only one right way." And no,
it's not. It's right what's it what's
right for you. And if it's not
infringing on anybody else's beliefs and
them or or or anything,
then it's right for you because what's
right for you may not be right for them.
So,
um,
the saying when Jesus said when Jesus
was healing the sick, the lepers and the
sick and the people were saying to him,
"Hey, hey, Jesus." I can s see him
saying, "Hey, God. Hey, Amen. How do you
do that?" You know, I'm being caught
now. How do you do that? That's so cool.
How,
Jesus? How do you do that?
That's so wonderful. And Jesus answered
them by saying, "Why are you guys
praising me?
It's not me that's doing the work." What
did he say? He said, "It's the God in me
that's doing the work." And he went on
to say, "These things that I'm doing,
you are able to do as well." and even
greater things. So that's what he that's
what he it that's what is meant by we're
we're limitless. We're abundant. All of
those things are not what we say but we
think is is from the physical world the
the the the the
five senses the logical world. And by us
thinking that way we have fallen from
the garden of Eden.
So in order for us to get back to the
Garden of Eden
where we live in peace and abundant and
good health, our thinking got to change.
And I and I once read that if you're not
working toward that toward working uh to
to to work toward working who to find
out who you really are and living from
that perspective that higher self within
us, the soul, the God within us. As
Jesus said, it's not me, the God in me.
He said, 'If you're not working toward
understanding and living from that
standpoint, then everything else is just
feudal. We're just going around and
around and around in circles. And guys,
that's why we we're going to always have
wars and rumors of wars because based on
human mankind,
this world doesn't teach and the
physical world doesn't teach peace. It
doesn't know how.
And it happened thousands of years ago
when when we fell from the garden of
Eden. We start living from
our physical world. We start living from
our our personal mental world and we
begin to leave the truth of ourselves
behind. And the world has been messed up
ever since. Relationships have been hard
ever since. And that's when we had to
start working by the sweat of our brow
because we fell from the garden of Eden.
Now if we want to get back then we have
to learn how to think and do
differently. Remember the the the the
parable or the the scripture be in this
world but not of this world. Now guys
this is an individual thing. You can't
look to your neighbor or to your sister
or to your children or to anybody else
and say, "Boy, it's going to be nice
when we all start living from that from
our real natural selves of abundance and
good self-esteem and peace and love,
right? It's going to be great." But it's
not designed that way. We can't change
other people. The only person we can
change is us as an individual.
That's the only person. Yeah. You know,
I used to think that way too. I was so
naive. I I you know, because I have a
good heart. I want to change people. I
want I want to see people do good,
right?
And so there was a time in my life when
I went around, well, God has blessed me
with this wisdom and and and this
insight at least and and I want to share
it with people. And I found out that I
was just wasting my time because most
people don't want to change. So, you
know, people have to want to do
something in order for them to get there
because there are challenges in between
those stairs, right? So, anyway, um
one of the things uh that we've been
taught to do and everybody on this call
uh knows it. We've been taught as human
beings to do what? Control and
manipulate.
Control and manipulate life and
situations. And that's why we're so
unhappy. We're trying to control things.
And and and with most spiritual
teachings, guys, or even wisdom you or
positive thinking, you you hear you you
hear all the time, I'm sure, on even on
this call. Surrender.
Let go.
We even teach it in our eight-step
program. Stay away from the outcome of
the sale or the situation. Well, we
should do that about everything in life.
This world has been here for, from what
I understand, billions of years. And it
was doing it and unfolding for billions
of years. And guess what? It did it
without us being here.
But we think that we're right about
everything. And if we don't lay our
hands on it, then things are not going
to work out the way. But if you want
peace in your business, in your just
trust.
Let go and trust. You hear it all the
time. But you got to do it. That means
let go.
Well, I can't do that because it might
not turn out the way I think it should
be. It's going to turn out. and it's
going to turn out the way it's going to
be and you don't have to be stressed
about it. Trying to make something turn
out the way you want. There's a lot of
stress behind that. But we've been
taught that guys. That's a pattern that
we have, right? So manipulating an
outcome or stressing it. It just keeps
you stressed out
all your life
and it ends up if you let it go, things
normally turn out better than you
expected them to if you learn to relax
and let it go. Now, you're not going to
do that uh
just by hoping. We're not going to do it
by hoping and wishing. We have to do the
work. The work's got to be done on an
individual basis. So I suggest this is
since I'm the speaker suggest that you
get books that teach you or or that
suggest to you how to think from your
higher self. See peace is not something
you work for. It's already in us.
Abundance is not something that we work
for. is already in us.
But we have to let go because that
control blocks
the natural flow and the manipulation
and the wants and the desires blocks the
natural flow of what's in you.
We're just not. We think with our five
senses that we know better than the
universe or God,
whatever you want to call your higher
power. And as long as we think and act
from that standpoint,
you're going to have to work and earn
from the uh sweat of your brow forever
and never be at peace and accomplish the
things that you could have accomplished.
Now, I want to say this.
because the ego is so slick. There is
such a thing as spiritual ego too. So
you got to watch it uh when when the
Bible says be careful where you get your
your wisdom from or your knowledge. So
be careful, ask for discernment.
And what I mean by that, you know,
question everything. Just cuz the crowd
is saying it and it sounds all good and
everybody's saying the same thing don't
mean it's right.
Because, you know, I'm one of the things
that I've learned is this.
it,
you know, not to to to to judge or or or
anything as Ruth Ellen was saying is
because
uh is is
because you know, you look around and
everybody's following everybody else and
nobody's at peace
and nobody's happy and everybody's
against each other. now
right because we're following the
processes of the ego in the world which
is in the end it always destroys us will
never reach our our natural state of the
god god within us so be careful and
watch so the next on your very next
decision that you make whether it's to
call somebody or to say something to
somebody. Ask yourself,
what's my motive behind this? Is it
because am I saying this because I have
low self-esteem? Because I I'm trying to
control that person or those people
because of my low self-esteem and I
don't know and I'm operating from man,
the man, the human being side of me and
not the real me. Am I making this call
to control
things
or am I making this call to be of
service and to help somebody? Because
everybody that we see, guys, if what I'm
saying is true and and I don't mean some
people going to think this is blasphemy
what I'm about to say, but it can't be
blasphemy if it's true. Even if we don't
understand something, it doesn't mean
it's not true. It just doesn't mean that
we haven't experienced that yet or we
just don't understand it. And that is
when you see somebody, whether it's a
drunker or a person, sick person,
whatever, you see God there. That's what
you see. You are that God in you is
there. And you can't get rid of it just
because you don't believe it or or or
somebody says it's blasphemy. That's why
Jesus said what he said. It's not mean
that doing the work. It's not it's the
God in me, guys. So,
you know, just just be careful
um if you want to be and get back to the
Garden of Eden u of of of change. And I
don't mean just behavior well stop doing
this you know it because if you don't
change at that spiritual level then uh
it's really not change at all because
getting put in the right predicament the
right situation those old patterns will
will will kick up. And last thing I'll
say about this, and I've been thinking
about this a lot lately, uh, uh, family,
that is, you know, we're always going
to, I mentioned this earlier, have wars
because we live, human beings live from
very unnatural, which is the human side
of us. The human being side of us. Well,
I'm only human. No, you're not. But
we've been, we hear that for and we use
that for an excuse.
We do it because that's what we're
programmed and that's what we know,
right? And we know it's not working. And
I, you know, one country gets
pissed off at another country because
they're doing this or they're doing
this. And every sense of they don't act
the way we act. You know, the Catholics
are mad at the Protestants and the
Protestants are mad at the the Jews and
so on and so forth. It's just God in us,
which is goodness in everybody. All this
outside stuff, titles, and all that kind
of stuff. It makes no difference. I can
see God now just saying, "Y'all are just
so sick." But all your titles and
wanting to be
separate and controlling somebody else
is just foolish and silly. So, uh, last
thing I I'll say is this. Watch
ourselves about
uh about things. Uh there was there's
this saying that says uh uh um
you don't have to lie to me
about
me. I think this says goes, you don't
have to lie to me. If I like you enough,
I'll lie to myself about you. So I'm
going to I don't know where we go with
that, but I'm going to leave it leave it
there. Do we have any questions behind
that? Ruth in Phyllis Marilyn uh anybody
else any questions about that? What uh
and the reason guys I I Ruth Ellen I I
wanted to come up with this stuff is
because in in Young
and and I mentioned this to Ruth Ellen.
We are programmed for products and
basically products only products and
socializing and network marketing was
not really developed for that. That's
why why Dr. Wall developed a a a
financial side to it. If he just wanted
people to buy products, he didn't have
to share that with us. He could just we
could just call in directly to his line
and he could sell them directly. But he
set it up where we could have some extra
money or a lot of money if you choose to
see. I believe this. There's no reason
for a person to get in this business and
not have money eventually,
right?
So, um, that's where I always come from,
guys, because I, in this society, we
live in a capitalist, you got to have,
right? And we don't have to to to trick
people or manipulate people or be
dishonest because
this network marketing when done right
and and if you can see it in depth with
wisdom and what it stands for and what
it's supposed to do for us in our family
inside and out
spiritually, physically,
emotionally, financially, all that. You
can't succeed in this business unless
you have a good heart for your other
brother. And even if that's in the
network marketing side of it, unless
you're able to help him get or her get
where they want to be, you this business
won't work for you or work for any of
us. So, it's a it's a beautiful
beautiful concept that that that that we
have here. So, with that, I'm going to
be quiet. I guess I've talked enough
hooping. So, Did you have guys have any
questions or comments? Just
>> Marilyn does have a question, but I
before I go to Marilyn, I just want to
say that, you know, one of the things I
love about network marketing is the fact
that you have to grow and you have to be
willing to help other people
grow.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, and
be set a good example. You I'm a
preacher's kid. Like my dad.
>> Oh,
>> I was a children's evangelist.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Are you now? Now, now,
now, now. My wife is not in here. I've
dated preacher's daughter. Are you
There's two sides.
>> There are two sides to that whole
>> You're the good twin.
>> What?
>> Are you the good twin or the bad twin?
>> I had my time as the bad twin.
>> Okay. Okay. I got 31 years sober now.
>> 31 years and I think six months sober
now. So,
>> wow. Congratulations.
>> Had to I went through that.
>> Yes.
>> I had to work on me to get where I am
and to be good person. Not that I wasn't
a good person, but I was now I'm a
better person than I was.
And um
>> I mean I
>> Yeah, my dad was a children's evangelist
and he had uh he used ventriloquism
to
>> What do you mean?
>> He was a ventriloquist. So he
>> Oh, in real for real.
>> For real. Yeah.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. He uh before he met my mom or
right after he met I'm not sure exactly
when he was on the Vegas strip in the
clubs doing ventriloquism.
>> Wow.
>> And uh yeah. So um now I forgot what I
was going to say,
but so we'll go to Maryland and then
>> train ran off the track. That's okay. It
happens to me all the time. It's okay
because um
yeah, I'll remember in a second. So um
Marilyn, do you like to answer ask your
question?
>> Okay.
>> Hello, Miss Marilyn.
>> You know what? I don't think a day goes
by where I'm not judging somebody.
And I think every argument I have with
my husband is why did you think that
way? I don't understand you.
>> Sure.
>> I mean, I can't believe how hard it is.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't think that's ever
going to change. I think it's an ongoing
thing that you have to do every
>> day.
>> I mean, is that true? I mean, I don't
know. Have you gotten to that point?
>> Well, well, you know, it's and Marilyn I
mean, um Ruthanne can tell you it's
about uh progress, not perfection,
right? So, it is not going to happen by
you saying, "I'm not going to argue and
I'm not going to judge anybody anymore."
It doesn't work that way. You got to
read. You got to study. You got to put
into practice. And you start with small
things like
when your husband says something that
ticks you off, you say, "This one time,
I'm not going to say anything. I'm not
gonna
>> That's a killer. I'mma just relax. Well,
well, you you know, I'm just I'mma relax
and let because all that is is ego,
right? Because we know what it is. It's
ego, right?
>> But we we say we can't help. Yes, you
can. You can you can help yourself. So,
you just do it that one time and then
maybe and you can argue your butt off
for the rest of the day. Then tomorrow
maybe you can do it two times or the
next two days. you know, start doing it
in a way, you know, the lowhanging fruit
or the next time somebody cuts you off
or turns in front of you and don't
signal, instead of cussing them off out
in your mind, you just relax and you
release because what good does that do?
That person gone gone about their
business and you in your mind you still
fussing and and causing stress on
yourself and they gone, right? And so
that's the way you do it. A little at a
time. You don't you're not going to
change overnight. You've been this way
for 30, 40, 50 years. Don't even put
that pressure on yourself, right? Just
change a little. Read a book. Now guys,
I read a whole lot the the and it's been
like a progre at one point in my life,
Maryanne Williamson was a a a a a a
mentor because she taught love, right?
Regardless of her political persuasion,
whatever, she taught love, right? And
that was about a five ten year stent
where that's what that's where I was I
was as we grow
more would will be revealed to you as
you grow right and so and then the next
thing that came into my life I mean
there were thousands of books before
then but I'm talking about when I got to
the point where I was really changing
right from the inside out not just
behavior. So, the next thing is uh um uh
um what's his name? Michael A. Singer. I
love that guy. He changed my life
completely. Now, guys, here's what I
want to say.
If you're reading something and
and just because you don't understand it
or it goes against certain things that
you've been taught, well, how is that
working out? If you keep following and
doing what you're doing, if you're
honest with yourself, are you really
growing from that standpoint? Ask
yourself, am I really growing from this
standpoint or I'm just staying here
because I'm in I'm in a comfortable
place but I'm not growing
right
>> the first step was when was when you
someone like you just brings it to our
attention.
>> Yeah.
>> To make us aware of it.
>> That that's the seems like at least I'm
aware.
>> Yes. That's my my heartfelt intentions.
It's we don't know what we don't know
until we become aware of it, right?
But you know when you become aware of
it, it does us no good if we're not
going to do anything about it. We're
just aware. It's like having your socks
on, washing your feet with your socks
on. It doesn't do any good
really until so so you know grab you and
and Michael Singer uh has all these
podcast right and because you don't
agree with him grab the parts that you
do agree or grab the part that's going
to make you stretch a little bit.
Listen, if we read everything and
listened to everything we already agreed
on, how could we grow?
That's impossible,
right?
Yeah. So, okay. Uh, so, so, so thank
you, Marilyn. I love Thank Thank you for
bringing that up. I love honesty, man.
>> And I like being us being just us. We
ain't got to be all professional when we
can get down and be honest and talk
about things that's that's real in life,
right? because all this other stuff. It
don't matter. It don't matter. Yeah.
Phyllis.
>> Yes. Hello. Um
>> my wife is not in here. Phyllis was one
of my favorite girlfriends in high
school.
Don't y'all tell?
>> Go ahead, Phil. Um, one of I I love all
all this that you're saying and it's
something we don't talk about often
enough, I think, or or I'm sure you do
in your working with people, but um, for
the rest of us, such a good reminder.
Um, and I wanted to zero in on something
you said about how people um, something
happens and you said, "Can you go back
and change that?" No, you can't. And
what happens is, as you brought up,
people rehearse that over and over in
their minds, they just can't let go of
it. And it's affecting them to this day.
Something that might have happened 20,
30, 40 years ago, something your mother
did or somebody said. And um my husband
Andy is kind of famous for uh delving
deeply into the word resentment.
Well, because we've got all these
layers.
>> Sure. And it's like an onion, you know,
you get the little ones at the top and
and oh my goodness, it just goes down
and down as you become more observant
and aware of this in your own memories
and reex rehashing in your mind where
you're not experiencing the present
moment, right? If you're back in your
mind.
>> But um the root of the word resentment,
I believe it's Latin re to do over and
over again. And uh I think the verb is
centur to feel. You refill it over and
over again. And that's the literal
meaning of the word resentment. And I I
really do think that these negative
emotions we experience of anger and
depression and frustration all go back
to some experience that we didn't let go
of. It's that's deep inside buried and
and we're resenting it still. And it's
so powerful just to uh use that as a
practice to observe. Am I resenting what
he just said or or what that guy said so
many years ago, you know, and why? You
realize it makes no sense and you you
just and and like you said, we don't
necessarily have the power to make it go
away, right? We just need to realize we
don't want that in there anymore and be
in that state of mind where we can let
go of it. And uh that's all I wanted to
say. But you've said so many powerful
things and they sound simple but they're
very deep. So I'm really enjoying it.
>> Well well thank you. Thank you Phyllis.
One of the techniques because you know I
I
somebody
Okay. So, one of the techniques um that
I've learned and I learned it through
through and I've been to all kind of
psychiatrists and 12step programs and
all of that. For me, one of the things
that helped me and the word resentment
wasn't even you. And he says this, the
way you you get rid of those resentments
is this
or or the way you you that past as you
were talking about, Phyllis, is when
they come up that thought from the third
grade and say we don't even go to family
reunions or class reunions anymore
because 50 years ago we still mad at at
at at at Janet
for taking my boyfriend or embarrassing
me. Right. Right. 50 years ago, we won't
even go or talk to them. Yeah. Our lives
should be just like you said, should be
when you meet that person, Janet, it
should be like the first time you met
her is today. And all that past is the
past because you can't change it. But
here's what it it it changed my life
because this resentment stuff, I
couldn't let it go. all that because all
that fear it was blocking me from the
sunlight of my blessings of blocking me
from the real me the God in me right so
here's what you do allow allow those
thoughts to come up whatever re resist
persist
right whatever we resist persist so
allow those negative thoughts I don't
care what it is how bad it is because
you can't change it, right? You can't
undo what's done. I'm not saying it was
good or bad or even evil,
right? Uh but when they come up, which
they come up if you're if you're
anything like me, they come up every
every two or three seconds all day every
day. And so what you do, you allow them
to come up. Don't try not to. Well, do
your best not to judge them because all
we're doing here is doing our best, not
being perfect. And it gets better and
better as time goes on the more we
practice it. Allow it to come up
because see, we don't like to feel that
hurt and feel we don't like to feel
uncomfortable, right? But knowing this
is part of the process. You're going to
feel uncomfortable. So allow these these
negative thoughts to come up or or
whatever to come up and then you
let them play out and then you say to
yourself, I relax and I release you and
you're going to be our the rest of our
lives we going to be saying I relax and
I release you for me because they coming
up all the time. I've been doing this
stuff for 55 years. I mean, you know,
I'm in my 70s. I've been been So, here's
what you say. And it might sound koi or
stupid or whatever or not even any depth
to it, but you but here's what changed
my life. You relax and you release. You
relax because when you allow that stuff
to stay down in there, it's like a
cesspool of rot, right?
And so every time if we allow if we
don't release this stuff, it stays
there. Just like going to a restaurant
and get some I guess you get some some
some spoiled food and take it home with
us and then every day take a bite of it.
That's a good analogy, I guess. But
allow it to come up. Don't run from it.
Don't like we've been been doing all our
lives, right? So we supposed to be in
control of ourselves now. Oh, that is a
bunch of crap, right? So, let it come
up. I don't care what it is, how bad it
is all day long. Relax and release. You
say that to yourself. Now, in the
beginning,
uh, Phillis
is not going to feel comfortable and
it's not going to because when I say
that, all these programs I've been to,
you think just saying that is going to
change anything? That was my my physical
body, my logical five senses saying
that. And then it says, "Well, you've
been trying it that way all your life.
Has it changed anything?" Nope.
Well, maybe you should try something
different, Mr. Smarty Pants.
Right. So, uh, so here's the technique,
guys. When those things come up, and
they mostly do all day long, you just
say to yourself, "Allow it. Don't push
it back down in there as if it hadn't
existed.
Allow yourself to feel uncomfortable. It
hadn't killed you to this point and it
won't kill you if you start using
something to re release it. Now, they're
going to keep coming up over and over. I
started doing this work uh relaxing and
releasing uh probably about
two three years ago and some of this
stuff still come up but it doesn't have
the same effect on me as it used to. I'm
not depressed
or get down
and a lot of things start happening to
you even physically. And that's why
people go insane is because we have all
these thoughts in our head of the past
and we don't know what to do with them.
We we're aware but we don't know what to
do. We can't change it. And then we the
p the future can be just as bad. We
start projecting the future's going to
be bad, right? or it's going to be that
like this and that's where lack set in
right so even with that and I wanted to
say something about that lack because
people think lack so when when you're
about to buy something or not buy
something
or
ask yourself this is this coming from a
place of lack the human side of me
because there is in reality our natural
yourself. There is no lack. Now, I'm not
saying go out there and spend, get in
debt, but you got to work your way up to
knowing that you're not lack.
>> Okay. Somebody had else had their hand
up. I guess I better
>> Keely did.
>> Keely,
>> if you want to unmute, Keely, you can
ask your question.
>> There you go.
>> Hi. How are you? How are you my dear?
Hey, how you doing?
>> Oh, I'm not too bad. Um, I want to go
back a little bit on what you said
because I love the fact when somebody
says let go because it's really about
surrendering
>> and we don't want to surrender to a God
greater than us. So we turn around and
we project our own inadequacies on
others instead of asking one simple
question that if I am judging somebody,
what about them is really about me that
I'm putting on them that I don't want to
see.
>> Yep. And if we so if you know like
Marilyn gave that example about you know
I judge my husband almost every day that
very honest statement that's because you
judge yourself and you project it out
because they're not meeting your thought
process. So then it's about going inward
and saying so what is it about me that I
judge because I can't give what I don't
have. And I think the benefit of
surrender is when we do our own work, we
work on our triggers and we understand
it, then we can give people
unconditional love and support without
the judgment.
>> Yep. You can't love anybody unless you
love love yourself.
>> And we think that we're going to find
that outside of ourselves. And Key, it
boils down to this what you're saying.
You can't fix an inside problem with an
outside solution.
>> You got it
>> right.
>> You got it.
>> Yep.
>> Thank you for that, Key. I appreciate I
love to learn.
>> Uh the other thing is about the
resentment. You know, resentment is I
call it a soul call. It's
>> what? I'm sorry. What did you say? You
call it a
>> a soul call that it's your mind, will
Yeah. Your mind, will and emotions have
unfinished business. And the resentment
that comes up is a call to heal. Your
soul wants to heal. So, it's going to
come through getting agitated or
triggered or frustrated. But it's about
you. It's not about who you're
projecting it to,
>> right?
>> And if people understand that if you
have a reaction or to something somebody
says, that's about you. It's not about
the other person. They're just telling
you who they are, what they believe, and
what they've experienced. They might not
be able to know what to do about it. But
to meet them where they are and ask one
question, so why do you believe that? It
changes the dynamic from judging them to
really seeking first to understand and
it so it it postpones all that judgment
because you're really then
uh coming alongside of them and say,
"Huh, well, that's interesting. Why do
you believe that? You might still be
triggered, but if you get the
information, you will understand what
about you is being triggered.
>> Yep.
>> So, thank you for bringing up um those
points.
>> No, thank you. I love to learn. Thank
you.
>> Yeah.
>> And I and I'll see you tomorrow night on
your call.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Come come come join us.
>> Okay. Thank you, M.
>> Thank Thank you, Keith. Yeah. So, so
guys, it's about um reading and guys,
don't get off off this call and just
say, "Oh, oh, Raymond was a good speaker
and we love his wisdom." I appreciate
that, guys. I really from the bottom of
my heart, I do, but it's if we don't do
anything about it, it's just
entertainment.
You know, we are grown folks here. We
have to do grown folks stuff,
right? I mean,
>> yeah.
>> Uh, this stuff that I mean, what are we
what are we projecting? What what what
are we inferring onto our children
and our grandchildren? See, they talk
about, and you've heard me talk about
this, that um, you know, uh, they talk
about what is that um, generational
wealth. You know, we leave our children.
Well, I think that is a very low bar
because I don't care how much you need,
they can marry the wrong person, they
can make bad decision, that wealth is
gone. Number of years, 10 years, it
could be gone. And there's some
statistics that back that somewhere. But
if you live from wisdom, from your true
self, because you got to remember guys,
this is not something extra that we're
doing. This is just getting back to who
we really are, our natural selves,
right? And that's why you you don't
search for peace.
It's already in us.
You search for that that God within you
on an individual basis. That goodness or
that that not even goodness that
the the principles that's in us that's
what you work anything else is just a
waste of time that you're working for
anything. It really is because that's
what it boils down to. All this outside
human behavior stuff. It doesn't doesn't
matter. Everything we have we leave in
here anyway. And if you don't I used to
when I was younger I used to hear people
say that but I didn't believe it. You
know I thought I was going to live
forever but now I got more yesterdays
than I do tomorrow. I know I ain't
taking none of this stuff with me. So
leave your children and your
grandchildren wisdom going. Let them see
you working toward getting back to your
natural state.
Somebody's always watching us, guys.
Believe it or not, it may be a niece, a
grandchild, a neighbor, a friend.
Somebody's always watching you. You
don't know it, but they are. So,
let's get on an individual basis, get
back to who you really are and be at
peace because those other people, I
mean, you know, these great I mean, I
think about Robin Williams who was a
great comedian. I love that guy, Morgan
Mindy and all that. killed himself and
it basically unless it was a chemical uh
uh dysfunction or something in his body
or brain that it was those thoughts that
makes us depressed those human thoughts
and you can't fix it from a human
standpoint you can't you can be guided
but you can't be fixed okay are we good
I see you stand I mean uh Ruth Ellen I
see you standing around must be time for
us to Is that my cue?
>> No, it's just Well, yeah, it is time to
go. But those are very um
>> I could talk about this stuff all day,
guys.
>> I know. That's one of the things I love
is that you just go and go. And all of
it is so true, you know, because we have
to choose to to release this things from
the past. And um
you know
being a person who um
has gone through uh the 12 steps and
sobriety and and I cannot change one
thing that I did way back when.
>> Right.
>> I can't change what I did five minutes
ago.
>> Right.
And I still we call it um people renting
space in your head for free.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, that's one of the things
people say, you know, and we I I'm
guilty of this. I allow people to rent
space in my head really quite often and
too much. And
I've had a lot of time to contemplate
over the last few years especially. And
um you know
life is really precious
and our minds are really precious and
how we feel and treat ourselves is even
more precious and how we treat other
people
is a reflection sometimes of how we feel
inside of ourselves. And it's very very
precious to treat people with kindness.
That is like one of the things I always
say when I sign off is to be kind
because nobody knows what somebody else
is going through. And sometimes what
they're going through is that internal
noise in their head that they can't shut
up. You know, I have a very dear friend
who I've known my entire life and I love
them like
more than family. You like they mean
something to me very much. So, and
sometimes this person gets really really
down and we get scared, you know,
>> and uh fortunately they reach out and we
talk about it as much as they will
allow, of course, but um you know, so
>> yeah,
>> that internal dialogue is just it can be
like you said with Robin Williams, it
can be deadly.
>> Yeah. It never leaves us alone. And
here's the thing, the mind can never if
once I accept it that the mind can never
figure stuff out. It never can. Now it
has its gift like it can can do things
certain things. It has it but it never
can figure stuff out. If we could it
could if it could figure it its stuff
out on a physical on a human basis
everybody would be at peace,
>> right?
>> You can write a book and everybody would
be at peace. But the thing is is to use
that technique of allowing it to come up
a thousand times a day and say to
yourself, I relax and I release you a
thousand times a day because it never
leaves you alone.
It never ever. Yeah. I'll say this, one
of the things because I was having this
conversation with u uh one of the guys
who's an executive for this this company
here in Houston and uh we were talking
about highly educated guy why we have
prejudices, right? And why we um why we
uh are mad at one another now, you know,
uh Republican, Democrat, independent.
And what it boils down to, you know why
why we have prejudices, guys?
>> Is because of our own low self-esteem.
>> We got low self-esteem. And that's the
bottom line.
>> Yeah, I could see that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's what it boils down
to. Low self-esteem. And we want
somebody to feel a certain way or think
a certain way
>> and they don't. And it affects our steam
because we're not we don't feel the mind
tells us we're not accomplishing what we
need to accomplish to feel good about
ourselves. So if I dislike you, that's
supposed to help me feel good about
myself. But it's only temporary because
after that's gone, after you hate that
person for whatever, here it comes back
again and you gonna hate somebody else
or some other group because that's
inside of you. And it's not the group,
it's not the husband, it's not the
cousin, it's us as Keely was saying.
Yeah. And as Phyllis was saying and you
think so.
>> That's very true. So we do have a
question.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Um you can say no and I could give this
person the information um in a different
way. But Bruce, who is loving you,
>> you're amazing. Thank you, Bruce.
>> He wants to know if it's okay to ask for
the link to uh Mr. Brown's Thursday
uh night uh meeting, but I don't know if
you want to put it out there on YouTube
and Facebook and everything, you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Of course, Bruce, man.
Everybody's in in uh is welcome to that
call. We've been doing that call 26
years now. Welcome to that call.
everybody and bring and you can even
bring guests because what it is we talk
a little bit about Dr. Wallik a little
bit. We talked uh a little bit about
Zradical because it's a on Thursday
night call Bruce unfortunately is not
any of this stuff we're talking about
today. It's about the product and
testimonials talk about for cordon right
and some people have every once in a
while some people talk about the healthy
start pack and and testimonials.
So that's basically what it's about. But
we have a good time, you know, we have
fun. And that's what this is all about.
Now, let me end by saying, well, I I'll
I'll stay alone if you want me to, but
have fun doing this, guys. Don't make
this so serious or your life. So, you
only got one time. Have fun. I heard
that one one now, I read that one time
that Earth is G is God's playground.
Have some fun while you're here. We only
go around in this in on in this chapter
one time from what I understand. So have
some fun. Don't be so serious about
about you know even when you're doing
your the work like relaxing and
releasing or when you're in the car I
relax my shoulders. I relax my chest. I
relax my stomach. Fun doing it. and say,
"Maybe every time I go through a door or
every time I'll use it then or whatever,
make fun of it. Make fun."
>> Yes, that's a good idea. Sometimes I'll
learned it. I don't I forget where. Um
when I need to release something and I
can't like let it go. um this girl I
used to know um I think I learned it and
met her in a raiki class or something
and she said just go like this with your
hands you know just turn the water on on
your sink and put on cold and then put
your hands around the stream and just
say release let it go and transmute it
with love and I'll tell you what that
saved my butt I don't know how many
times because I wanted to kill somebody
>> hey whatever works for you whatever
works for for you.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Whatever works for you. Uh but
that that technique seems to the other
technique seems to
>> Yeah. I mean, but that was just my way
of being able to kind of visualize it
going away from me and really
>> you're gonna kill somebody.
>> Tell you you were hot, man. You were
mad.
>> We all been there.
>> Well, thank you so much for today. It's
it's we've gotten a lot of comments
about um
you know um Olga has said um suicide is
on an increase and men sadly are men
it's moving on me I'm sorry um
men sadly are more successful at it we
lost a young colleague recently so yes
be kind and we're so sorry Olga I'm so
sorry
>> yeah sorry but just think about This
guys, think about this. If we could
start our children out thinking this way
from and letting them know that they're
much more than human, that they're
really inside the God and they're much
more than the education. They're much
more than the house. They're much more
than what we call worldly success.
They're bigger than that. If we could
start living that and teaching that
where they see it, think about the lives
we could save because everybody's trying
to use common sense and logic
>> to save to to you know to get through in
life and it doesn't work. And as you say
as Oka was saying and there there's more
people dying and dying now with this
social stuff, these children dying. What
if we could teach them and we could save
one, right? What if this after this
conversation that we're having today,
somebody was depressed, right? And we
could save them one day or one hour of
depression. Now they have the tools.
They have the awareness first of all,
and now they have the tools of being
able to relax and release. And I want to
suggest to everybody, you use what you
want to use, but there are podcast
uh with Michael Singer. I don't get no
money from that, by the way, guys. All
right. Um that you can listen to. All he
got hundreds of them you can listen to
all day long that will help you if
you're willing to just a little bit put
it into practice just a tiny bit each
day.
>> Yes. the list.
>> Yes, that's that's
>> um I have this thing I do uh
that I don't know. I just started doing
it when I first got sober and it was
like I had five second days and then it
was 10 and it was 20 and then it was
five minutes and I I have a coin that
says um 10 minutes. I can do anything
for 10 minutes.
>> I have given several of my sponses and
um a dime like just
hold the dime and count it as 10
minutes. Just do whatever it is for 10.
>> Change your thoughts.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not getting
it.
>> Okay. So,
I'm gonna get real green here.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah, we're here to learn.
>> Okay. So,
Oh, I'm gonna admit this. Okay. Well, I
used to smoke crack and drink alcohol
and do all kinds of drugs and I never
injected anything.
>> I would have been I would have been
smoking crack in college. I did it all
that was available. Crack just wasn't
around.
>> Yes.
>> And it was great. It was a great
learning experience. I don't regret any
of it.
>> Yes. Well,
I can't 100% say that. But I did learn a
lot in my journey. Can I say something
>> before and then I'll be quiet. Every
blade of grass that we stepped on
>> was necessary in order for us to become
the people that we are today.
>> This is true. I'm still working on
forgiving myself 100%.
>> Okay.
Um, so when I got sober and my hands
were used to doing certain things to
satisfy my brain's need for chemicals,
um, I would repeat to myself, I can do
this. I don't need to do that. I can do
this. I can do this. So I had days where
it was five seconds in between thoughts
of I can do this. I don't need to chop a
line or smoke weed or whatever it was.
>> Five seconds.
>> Yeah,
>> it was five seconds and then it was 10
and then it was like a whole minute and
then it was longer and now it's 31 years
and I think six months. I don't know how
many days that is, but I have a count a
calculator thing that it's a se sober
one that would tell me how many
thousands and thousands of days I have.
So when I meet somebody,
I say, and this is true for me. I mean,
you know my story the last few years,
which we're not sharing here.
>> I had to just get through everything 10
minutes at a time.
So it was 10 minutes and then so that
dime represents
10 pennies, right? So I would tell my
sponses, you know, 10 minutes. If you
need to hold a penny, hold a penny.
whatever it is that you can like focus
on something tangible that you could
feel.
>> Mhm.
>> Cuz then you're not thinking
I want to go leave and go down the block
where I can get whatever. I can be right
here and just do 10 minutes and then you
can even set a timer and then like do
something for 10 minutes to occupy
yourself, you know, and then before you
know it, you have years of sobriety,
years of peace in your mind because, you
know, some people
are alive because of that.
>> Wow.
>> I mean,
>> that's that little technique right
there.
>> Yeah. I'm going to get emotional. Sorry.
>> Yeah, it's okay.
>> No, no, sorry. That was a
So, anyway, we do need to um
mm Rod I think out there on YouTube is
saying hello everyone. Raymond is so
insightful and practical. It's a fact
that to be in this business, you have to
be a better person first. And yes, you
do. Yes. Yes, you do. Um,
>> thank you, coach. Yeah,
>> that brother one of my favorite. I I
love He gets on our calls. I love Rod. I
love Coach Rod.
>> Yeah. What What I'm going to end by
saying this because I know it's time for
us to go.
>> Well, the
guys, what I'm sharing is nothing
uh like out of out of the out of the
norm. All of us, each and every human
being, if you would, every being that's
born, regardless of their uh born with
brain uh dysfunctions or physical uh uh
dysfunctions,
we was born with this spirit, this God
within us, this wisdom within us. It's
not something that's given to some
people. Some people may be able to
express it in a way, but each and every
one of us
have this. And when we get off this call
today, that's something that you should
acknowledge and you're going to have to
accept
if you want to live and be the person or
the spiritual being you were designed to
be. You came here to be. You see, you
have it in you. It's not like, "Oh,
Raymond is so special or or pastor so
and so is so special and and all of
that." No, it's you. You have to take
responsibility for that. You're the
greatest thing that ever walked the face
of this earth
because you were designed that way and
nobody can can take that from you but
you. So when you find yourself thinking
all them crazy thoughts, relax, release
it, and start that'll start heading you
back to who we really are. And that's a
whole chain of dominoes once that start.
The children and the friends in the
neighborhood begin to pick up on it and
they and and there's a saying where I'm
some I'm from. I'm from the streets,
guys. I'm from the hood. But I'm
educated. So I've been on both sides.
There's a saying in the hood,
I can't hear what you're saying for what
you're doing. You can talk to all the
good game you want to, but what does
your action say? And get in church and
hoop and holler and we can get together
how good God is. But are you at peace?
Are you living abundantly? Are you
living with good self-esteem?
Are you doing the work? Because now
you're aware of you can't go back. Once
the bell is rung, it's wrong. Now what
are we going to do about it to become
who we were really born to live or how
we were really born to live? So with
that,
>> thank you so much. This has been
>> really amazing and powerful.
And um so I want to thank my co-hosts
who have been here helping. And so we
have Marilyn who has been
>> Marilyn going at your husband
>> going at him.
>> She's been typing almost every single
word that you say
>> in the in the Zoom chat. That's the
benefit of being here. So she's been
typing away to make sure that um
everybody can have it the information if
they want to take a screenshot. I'm
sorry, I got a little emotional there.
No, I'm not. Sorry. I gotta stop saying
that.
And then we have Phyllis who is also um
helping with the chat and um is also out
there on the different platforms and
helping out that way. And also you she's
uh
she's a sweet lady and I appreciate her
very much too. Appreciate you all.
>> Thank you all for do for being here and
doing that. you don't know
>> what you're doing for people out here.
>> You know, you just get on after a while.
You know, it's kind of like having a
Rembrandt on your wall, right? It's a
beautiful thing. It's something you can
brag about, but eventually you come down
the stairs and you see it on the wall.
It just is just a PR picture, right? And
we take that for granted. Even we take
ourselves for granted for doing this
these things sometimes. So, you know,
give yourself a pat on the back for
doing it. You're being of service.
>> Yes.
Yes, very much. And then we have Sherry
who is part of our tech crew and she
helps set everything up.
>> She takes what I send to her and puts it
out onto the different platforms. And
today she's been our gatekeeper as well
because Albert is away at another event
today. So thank you Sherry and thank you
Albert for what you do when you're here.
>> And she's got part of my name too. I
like Sherry Brown.
Amazing.
And then we have Rod who's out there on
the different platforms and
talking to people and then helps out
with the gatekeeping when necessary. And
um so thank you for all that you do,
Rod.
And um I'm
>> Yeah,
I'm Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I just want
to thank you all for joining us today
and also want to give a shout out to AJ
who had to leave early. Um, thank you
for all that you do, our digital
marketing director. Um, and if you would
like to call and um, talk to a certified
holistic health coach, um, our phone
number is 8559493377.
And if you're struggling out there,
there are suiciderevention hotlines. I
don't have the number, but
please reach out to somebody.
Um, and then, um, if you have questions
for us or want to make a comment to
Raymond, you can, um, email us at, um,
questions dailywithdoc.com.
And this program was for educational
purposes only. And I
think I've said everything. Um, I'm very
emotional right now. This is amazing. I
love it. Um, be kind.
Be kind. Just be kind and show love. And
if you can't, walk away.
Give yourself a minute.
Anyway, thank you, Raymond. I can't wait
till you're on again. And I know your
lovely wife is going to join us next
month. And um, thank you so much. Thank
you all. Thank you all so much. And
we're going to be I I suppose I announce
this. We're going to be Yolanda and I
are going to be on the um on uh um Stan
and Lor's call. Lawrence call tonight. I
think it's 7:30. Is that 7:30 Central
time?
>> Think so.
>> Coach, it is. Okay. So, we're going to
be there talking about uh for cord and Z
radical and those types of things and
what it does and that kind of stuff. So,
thank you.
>> All right. Thank you so much and um have
a beautiful day everyone and we'll see
you again tomorrow and we our guest
tomorrow is Adrien Gold. So, we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow. Thank
you so much everybody. Bye for now.
>> Thank you. Bye-bye.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science and Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor,
Thank you.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.